lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
empezar a visualizar la hoja de balance
de un banco muy sencillito con esto
vamos a poder entender las mecánicas de
cómo un banco hace su contabilidad ya
sabe su activo y su pasivo en un sistema
bancario de reserva fraccionaria
entonces primero vamos a hablar de la
hoja de balance en otros vídeos lo he
visto con un poco más de profundidad
pero ahorita la idea muy en general es
que una hoja de balance es simplemente
nos dice cuánto activo tiene alguien
cuánto pasivo tiene y por tanto cuánto
le sobra en otras palabras cuánto tiene
de capital entonces digamos por ejemplo
vamos a poner por aquí una compañía
hipotética van así cualquier compañía y
supongamos que esta cajita de aquí verde
déjamelo dibujo más derechito esta
cajita de aquí es su activo
voy a poner así en color verde la altura
más o menos es la cantidad y digamos que
estos son 100 millones que la compañía
tiene 100 millones en activo un activo
pues a lo mejor lo piensas como algo que
te da un beneficio una definición más
formal es algo que te da un valor en el
futuro y que se considera económicamente
con un valor positivo puede ser efectivo
porque el efectivo lo puedes cambiar por
otras cosas verdad puedes comprar una
vaca la vaca te la leche y la leche es
un beneficio futuro la vaca por si mismo
ser un activo un edificio también sería
un activo porque usted da el valor
futuro de darte refugio aquí nada más
para simplificar las cosas vamos a
pensar estos 100 millones como efectivo
entonces tiene 100 millones de pesos en
efectivo supongamos que tiene también un
poco de pasivo esta caja que estoy
poniendo por acá digamos 60 millones en
pasivo más o menos es la altura verdad
entonces supongamos que tienen 60
millones en pasivo
pasivo un pasivo simplemente es una
obligación entonces le debe a ciertas
personas 60 millones de pesos verdad
entonces cuando lo ves de esta forma
esta compañía
no se ve incluso podría ser una persona
verdad tiene 100 millones de pesos pero
debe 60 millones entonces cuánto le
sobran los saberes con 100 menos 60
entonces lo que le sobra lo que es de él
es 40 40 millones entonces 40 millones
responde a la pregunta de realmente
cuánto tienen los propietarios de esta
compañía entonces sería 100 menos 60 y
entonces sería 40 millones de capital 40
millones se llama capital o bien el
capital de los propietarios lo pongo por
aquí el capital de los propietarios
entonces esto de aquí es una hoja de
balance muy sencillita con activo pasivo
y capital pero quiero construir a partir
de eso la idea de un sistema bancario de
reserva fraccionaria lo que vamos a ver
es que la forma en la que se hace
mecánicamente actualmente se hace un
poco diferente a la idea que tenemos o
al menos la idea que te he estado dando
porque pues de hecho te ha ayudado así
porque es más fácil pensarlo así pero
empecemos con un banco supongamos que yo
quiero empezar un banco y lo que voy a
hacer es que no sé o sea tomo y compro
vamos a comprar un banco que ya exista
va entonces voy a comprar un banco de 10
millones de pesos que ya exista entonces
aquí tengo un activo que yo ya sabes es
el edificio las bóveda de las
computadoras todo lo que se necesita
para abrir el banco eso vale 10 millones
de pesos y aquí tenemos mi capital
verdad aquí tenemos 10 millones de
capital de los propietarios deja lo
pongo con el color verde que puse arriba
estoy aquí en verde que es un activo y
no tengo nada de pasivo verdad
supongamos que heredé el dinero o que lo
estuve ahorrando toda mi vida entonces
ese activo de 10 millones me da un
capital verdad porque no tenemos nada de
pasivo entonces estoy aquí es mi capital
10 millones de pesos y es el capital
ahora supongamos que ya abrí mi banco
verdad está súper impresionante tú lo
ves y dices uff está súper padre está
súper bonito y decides que vas a
depositar todo tu dinero ahí en el banco
bueno un poquito entonces supongamos que
tomas no se te ganaste la lotería y
entonces vas a depositar 100 millones de
pesos en mi banco así en efectivo a ver
deja lo pongo por aquí básicamente son
billetes pues son reservas deja lo pongo
aquí en el activo
entonces son 100 millones de pesos
entonces vamos a ponerlo por aquí déjalo
por un poco más derechito y entonces lo
vas a depositar en mi banco son 100
millones de pesos
no voy a poner efectivo efectivo lo
podemos visualizar así como billetes que
están en las bóvedas que compre entonces
eso de ahí es el activo que tengo pero
obviamente tú no me lo estás regalando
verdad no es para mi capital en realidad
me lo estás dando pero pues lo quieres
tener a la vista lo quieres en una
cuenta de cheques para poder pagar cosas
después para expedir cheques entonces yo
tengo un pasivo correspondiente lo pongo
por aquí y me no en verdad lo voy a
poner en el color de pasivo pero mi
pasivo correspondiente básicamente es
que es un depósito tuyo que te lo debo a
ti déjame escribirlo por aquí depósitos
en cheques
che x ahora lo estoy haciendo desde la
perspectiva del banco y por eso es un
pasivo verdad es un pasivo porque si
alguien viene con un cheque que tú le
diste entonces yo lo voy a tener que dar
efectivo y es una obligación cuando
alguien escribe un cheque por estos
depósitos a alguien más esa es una
obligación que yo como el banco tengo
que satisfacer tengo que pagarlo en
efectivo pero sabes que en vez de
ponerle así cuentas de cheques dejar
ponerle la cuenta de cheques de a no le
había puesto verdad bueno voy a poner la
persona entonces es la cuenta de cheques
de la persona y bueno esto de aquí otra
vez es un pasivo porque la persona a
puede venir en cualquier momento y puede
exigir 100 millones de pesos en efectivo
o expedir cheques o lo que sea pero
bueno ahora hasta ahorita no he hecho
nada fraccionario ahorita es muy regular
de hecho hasta ahorita es equivalente a
la reserva completa estoy guardando todo
el dinero de la persona
pero sabemos que en un sistema de
reserva fraccionaria puedo prestar un
buen cacho de esto verdad entonces eso
es lo que vamos a hacer ahorita déjame
borrar estos 100 millones de pesos en
efectivo voy a prestar el 90 por ciento
borrar voy a dar
poner en negrita hasta entonces
supongamos que tengo los 100 millones
pero de esos 100 millones prestó 90
millones entonces solo voy a guardar 10
millones en reservas lo voy a poner aquí
abajo ahora tengo 10 millones en
reservas sea en efectivo en billetes en
la bóveda y lo demás lo voy a prestar
entonces todo lo demás lo voy a prestar
podemos pensar así 90 millones de fajos
de billetes los prestó deja dibujó los
fajos de billetes para que lo
visualicemos mejor ahí estando un montón
de billetes que preste y ahora pensemos
en lo siguiente estar acá no no lo
regale verdad a cambio me están dando
algo a cambio me están diciendo que me
van a pagar y eso es un activo ahora si
tú pides prestado dinero mío es una
obligación para ti pero es un activo
para mí déjame escribirlo si yo soy el
banco si yo soy el banco y hago un
préstamo
a alguien déjame ponerlo aquí alguien
pide prestado y entonces si a esa
persona le doy no sé un peso voy a
ponerle aquí un peso entonces podemos
imaginar esto como que a cambio me das
un pagaré no funciona así exactamente
pero la idea es que en el futuro me
pagaras un peso ahora desde el punto de
vista del valgo este pagar es un activo
verdad esencialmente estamos
intercambiando activos estamos
intercambiando un peso por un pagaré por
un peso desde el punto de vista del que
pidió prestado este peso es un activo y
este pagaré es un pasivo para el banco
que obtiene el pagaré obtiene un activo
y este pagaré es un activo porque al
final de cuentas le va a dar al banco un
beneficio futuro vaya incluso se puede
vender pero usualmente nada más se cobra
es un activo siempre y cuando la persona
te pague por esa misma razón un cheque
es un pasivo para el banco pues o sea
cuando le das un cheque a una persona él
puede ir al banco y el banco tiene que
satisfacer esa obligación tiene que dar
el efectivo a esa persona
bueno vemos similar cuando un banco da
mucho dinero entonces va a obtener
muchos pagarés y entonces aquí va a
tener 90 millones de pesos y en pagarés
para ver si podríamos ponerle 90
millones de deudas pero vamos a ponerle
90 millones de deudas para esto de aquí
son pagarés y es un activo porque le da
el beneficio futuro de recibir ese
dinero lo voy a dejar aquí porque lo que
he hecho hasta ahorita pues es
conceptualmente idéntico a todo lo que
hemos estado platicando así casi todas
las personas imaginan la reserva
fraccionaria o sea obtiene un montón de
dinero el banco presta 90 millones de
eso y a cambio obtiene un activo que
básicamente son pagarés pero lo que
vamos a ver en el vídeo siguiente es que
las cosas funcionan de manera un poco
distinta en realidad el banco puede nada
más recibir 10 millones de pesos y luego
puede crear este activo es
funcionalmente igual se ve un poco
obscuro la primera vez que lo piensas
pero al final de cuentas las hojas de
balance se van a quedar básicamente
igual bueno lo veremos en el siguiente
vídeo hasta pronto